you're watching the GameSpot co-op stage
sponsored by Lego Star Wars The Force
awakens
what's up guys I'm Tim Geddes and this
is the one and only logic hello how's it
going mr. rapper I guess this is an
honor
oh it's a pleasure out of you so nice to
meet you this Thank You super super
awesome majority three is this your
first this is my first time oh my god is
that how I look right now Jesus you are
I'm nervous this is like my rep I know
I'll go out and perform in front of
thousands of people but this is like oh
my god you're a rapper a rapper I've
come in I am a musician the game stuff
has always been there I used to play
video games to escape from the world
because I hated my job and just like you
know and I escaped but now I play these
video games to enhance my life I love it
I've always been a gamer
it's crazy cos Kurt one of the lead
developers from Naughty Dog is over
there I can still use their fan from the
rope yeah yeah yeah so Uncharted so I
beat like just to put it in perspective
I beat the last of us ten times and now
I'm on my 11th playthrough cuz why not
cuz why not good flex anyway no but I
love I I love video games and I think
one thing about this though like the
reason I'm so excited and you know
filled with smiles and all this is
because like I truly love it I'm a part
of this community and I think a lot of
at least in my kind of realm of music
with hip-hop you got to be all like you
got to be cool I'm like no I'm straight
drastic park and yeah that's it yeah but
like for me man I just I just love being
myself and a big part of this is I love
that people can come together of all
races religions color creeds and we just
love okay it's just like listen the
energy in this room is ridiculous insane
you walk in you're just overwhelmed with
just fun it's just wow this up man yeah
it's super glad to see anything yet
today yes I saw the God of War I went in
there and saw what that was like and
that's insane I'm excited for a days
gone right that's what is wrong yeah I'm
excited to see that battlefield 1
because I love and I mean call duties
awesome totally of course but you're
like oh god no no it's not even that I
love Call of Duty but I I'm just excited
to go back yeah you know you're kind of
my classic World War
man I mean it's pretty like we haven't
really seen that video I haven't really
seen that since I guess world at war
right back in like waiter
oh nice we gotta forget what it was well
yeah it was a long time ago but yeah so
for me I'm kind of excited to just to
see that you know just to be there and
be back in that era in time but in HD
yeah it's crazy so yeah I'm excited
you play any overwatch yes I played
overwatch it's so I'm like dealing with
this lag issue right now on my on my on
my game capture card you know I'm a
console I'm a console go guy but I am a
PC got on the road so razor razor just
sent me this insane yet they're like
newest laptops amazing so I downloaded I
have The Witcher on there I'm on my
third second playthrough The Witcher if
you're you're big fan of replay in the
game of course okay what do you stream
them I stream
I mean yeah sometimes I stream but I
love to just capture them and kind of do
a little segment okay so YouTube channel
I have a YouTube channel it's a new comm
slash logic 301 very very simple ello
GIC 3:01 I love it I love video games I
can't believe I'm here right now yeah no
I love it I mean I just I beat doom in a
day I beat uncharted 4 in like 15 hours
like the straight playthrough I have an
issue
how good it wasn't charted for by the
way it was what I mean it's arguably the
best game I've ever played oh my god I
was like you're gonna ask Kurt I don't
know where he is but I was getting like
Kurt from Naughty Dog and like Arnie and
like I was like this is so Neil
druckmann Neil I I met Neil I shook I
shook the gods hand
oh yeah when I went to Naughty Dog cuz
they let me play it they let me play it
yo bro so I went to Naughty Dog before
the game was out and then they gave it
to me 10 days early which was like so
epic and but I played it in this like
theater something like took me into this
huge like this awesome theater and I got
to play it and it was just incredible
with Kurt and Kurt was there but I
didn't even know I was like I'm just
such a fan of like everybody I haven't
like write them a letter I wrote the
whole naughty dog a letter and was like
thank you so much for what you do you
don't understand and then I felt I was
like oh my god because I've experienced
this with like fans and my music like oh
logic is what your music means to me and
I was like oh my is this what this feels
like
well I do that's the best thing about
doing what we
do here and like being here it's like in
a weird way there's so many so many
awesome best friends out there that are
coming asking for pictures with us and
I'm like this is weird
we're all just here having fun having
fun it's such a cool thing to be able to
give back and talk to the developers and
say thank you know they're all that
they've done for us and giving us years
and years and years of fun and memories
and happiness you're gonna replay the
same game a thousand times I mean they
changed the world like these people have
literally changed Gaming change
entertainment changing everything so I'm
just excited to even be a part of it and
have a little channel that people like
you know that I'm I'm extent awesome and
I got I gotta check out yeah do you do I
talk over sulfur yeah well I do like I
did a review of Uncharted you do not
like to make it fun like I keep it all I
don't overdo it
I edit all my videos everything like I
went out through yourself yeah I bought
a laptop specifically to edit on I got
you know stuff to film and record and
all this other stuff and I just loved it
and I just have fun yeah I'm not doing
it for some money or the Adsense so then
there's sort of that I mean that's cool
no I'm like I'm blessed I've made all my
money I just bought a house off month
off music yeah so this like for me is
just fun as fun as it gets
Oh am i excited for zelda yes dog like
obviously I love ocarina of time the new
Zelda so it's uh I don't have a Wii
uh-huh that's fine I know I know I know
I need I think I think I'm definitely
gonna look into it but I'm a big
PlayStation guy good that's your name
drop the winning team I love PlayStation
for life and people are always like why
you know what's the difference man just
xbox or one I'm like nah dog I don't
know if you know Greg Miller and kind of
funny all of us kind of the biggest
PlayStation fan definitely in good
company I love it have you had holy [ __ ]
this guy there you go I mean have you
done the VR yet oh yeah of course I went
to the I went to the PlayStation HQ yeah
and in the bay up in San Francisco San
Francisco obviously yes yeah and it was
it was crazy yeah no it was wild man was
insane man the only other time I did VR
was without you know Justin roiland is
Justin whoo Justin roiland he's the
creator of the show called Rick and
Morty oh of course
yeah Maury already talking about anyway
so he's like a really good buddy of mine
I love this guy so awesome and the first
time I ever tried VR was in his living
room
he's got it hooked up to his steam and
it's it's wild yeah I think watch any of
the press conferences yesterday I didn't
I didn't get the chance because like I
said I'm in the middle of moving into my
first home which I'm excited flex there
you go yeah I love this guy who just
keeps clapping for me what's your name
what is it Pablo won Pablo Oh more logic
now it's getting anyway shout out this
guy sorry yes so since I'm moving into
my new place I have I didn't have the
chance but I kind of caught a bit of the
recap and I talked to my friend Dino his
name is Ron style he's the guy who said
help me on the whole gaming channel yeah
he's the bomb and he he's ecstatic about
everything here last night was unreal
yeah announcements were saying dude you
see him walking you need to watch it I
know I didn't see it I'm the walks out I
read the book or just walks out he goes
I'm back that's my wife she loves crash
me oh my god me too
me too I am at romantic it's late so
Norman Reedus I was like wow and then
the thing with like the umbilical cord
and the baby and you're like what the
what's going on I was cursed got a war
looking awesome that's crazy yeah days
gone everything that Sony really killed
yes everybody did man yesterday was
really really solid yeah yeah to rub
this up a bit what are you excited see
later today honestly I'm just like
straight up not even specific for games
or this or that I'm just excited to be
here man
I don't even know how this happened I've
only walked over here with my buddy
Brian and then I see Greg he's like yeah
man you're gonna go sit on the couch so
I'm like I'm just I'm excited I love
video games there you go flex yeah hey I
gotta say though incredible true story
probably definitely gotta check it out
I'll tell people a little a little bit
about it cuz I really like how it's kind
of a concept album yeah story and kind
of like what is the spin it will in a
nutshell the incredible true story and
transformation of the man who saved the
world is a script that I wrote in one
night I have Steve Blum who's plates
spike on Cowboy Bebop
he's in video games everything he plays
this main character and in the Year 2065
the last human footprint was left on
earth before ascending to a space
station called Babel where we are then
scouring the the known universe for a
habitable planet it's kind of like rap
interstellar you know
to be honest I love Nolan but I mean for
me like I just wanted to do something
that was different you know making a
whole rap album about sci-fi and all
this other stuff and that's cool it's
out right now but even beyond that man I
just dropped a song called flex ik you
sure it's out it's on iTunes it's on
Spotify it's everywhere it's fun it's
turn up for the summer just have a good
time flash great man you're on tour now
I'm sorry you're on tour now with gez
going maybe ever join a co-headlining
tour i mean wild we're doing the form in
LA we're doing a Barclays Center
together
I'm gonna go rap I even think about it
cuz like people are like I even get
stopped here and people like oh my god
like I'm like yeah I'm just trying to go
play some video games like I just I
don't know man I'm a regular dude I came
from nothing section 8 welfare nothing
I'm here I'm blessed I'm married I got
my little puppy and I love video games I
mean that's all I focus dude thank you
so much thank you brother coming through
man so much you see very much follow him
everywhere
young Sinatra 301 flex YouTube logic 301
sweaty tune right here now gamespot 83
2016 get hyped that was awesome